hi
today i'm going to
talk about uh something different than
aikido
i'm going to talk about meditation
and a few other thoughts
here in the uk i got up at seven
to do my yoga and the sun was shining
blue skies a few fluffy clouds
got a gorgeous view this is my bedroom
designed the house ourselves design it
with a massive window
so that i can look up and
see all the beauty around us
this space is that
i have under floor heating so it's very
comfortable in winter
and in summer it doesn't come on so
i've got the best of both worlds
a lot of us are always so busy running
running our lives running around
we don't really have time for myself
and then perhaps one day we get a
partner
have a family and the running
seems to become more intense
we find that we don't have any time for
ourselves or the children
start to need to be taken places do
things life can become a little bit
severe things can get on top of us
we may even have the thought that we'd
like to run away from it all
if you've got an understanding partner
male or female it doesn't matter
as a human being the world to me
is going a speed that
not really controllable by
one person and
you may think you would like to run away
but because of your commitments you can
only do it once or twice a year
if you're lucky
you may choose to go on a retreat
of your choosing i just want to talk
today rather than about aikido i want to
talk about the meditation part
so you can run away by
meditating learning how to meditate
give it time when you can
i find it better in the morning but i
can do it any time of the day
try to if you if you're hungry you've
got some hunger pains
before you do it have a biscuit or
something don't have much
food just just take away that hunger
feeling
perhaps a sip of water or
even a cup of tea it doesn't have to be
herb until you can be whatever you like
i don't know about coffee because i
don't drink coffee now
but in moderation
just so that you can be comfortable
this is a a lesson
that i will publish on my patreon site
as well as
to all of you out there around the world
who wish
to look at it and spend time listening
to me
i hope that uh some of you will choose
to
join me on my patreon site because i'm
i'm going to take us all on a journey my
journey that i've lived so far
and all the things i've done
and hopefully together we'll find a more
peaceful enlightenment
i'm pretty much comfortable where i'm at
nowadays
because i've been working on it for
nearly 50 years now
people may say oh is that all you do you
only do
you anything you ever talk about is
martial arts
but then when you ask them if they've
got any hobbies they perhaps have
perhaps they've got more than one
they'll have lots of
things they like and
we've all got things an expanse of
things
not many people get up in the morning go
to work go home
and if they do and they're enjoying it
then that's their life
so
meditation to me is the food
that we need to escape the world
without going on a buddhist retreat
shaolin monastery
martial arts campus
go to the himalayas try and find peace
go somewhere on the river now
somewhere where you and your mind feel
that it's spiritual
you think that you'll find yourself
when you won't you'll be the same person
as our hands sitting here
in cambridge
happiness is searching yourself
giving yourself the space and time that
you need
and take a little bit of that time for
yourself
what i do is i sit today i've chosen to
sell this
yoga lock just to tip my pelvis i'm
going to use my bed
a little bit of a back rest
place my feet like this
and on the patreon site i go into far
more detail about this
but just for now don't sit in this what
you
consider the perfect
pose that you you'll see a picture of
put your hands where it's comfortable
where it's comfortable
if you do like you know because this is
the sign
putting it on
expand try try this
and follow me and
find out who you are where you're going
what you're doing oh since he didn't
just do techniques
his whole life but the end
part when he went to obama to build his
dojo
it was like a spiritual sanctuary for
him
across from the dojo he got ginger
it's a very odd wooden building
it's very nice now because it's been
done up modernized and tidied
refreshed but you first built a
most oddest structure that you can see
pictures of
and i don't know why he built it but
obviously for religious reasons
but that's up to us if we want to make
it a religious
path or not so what i'm going to do is
i'm just going to relax find a place
where i'm comfortable
um i like the bell
i like this belt a lot i bought it when
i was in japan
it's a bong spell striker
again i go into a lot of detail on the
patron site
you know you can try and selling here
but you can try it for a month if you
don't like it
answer you know stop paying
to the western world it's a very small
fee
and you could enjoy you can go up
even to have one-to-one according me
once a month zoom meetings
ask me all the questions that you need
answering
if i can answer them i will
i take the striker and it's got to fit
back into
this with my eyes closed
[Music]
with my eyes closed i needed to be in a
perfect position so i
keep moving it about until it feels
comfortable
i'm not going to get annoyed if it's not
and i'll
with my clothes i shall take it out of
the
thing and just as a blind person would i
have to feel where the bowl is
i change the angle of the striker
feel the shape of the bowl
and this is why i shall wing it
several times until the sound becomes
loud
i should place the striker back
with my eyes closed i shall
take the resonance of the bowel inside
my chest and
allow it to vibrate as i calm down and
go inside myself
now i have on my other films i talk
about it but i have an
inner body and an outer body
my outer body's been abused most of my
life being a manual worker
pushed it too far too hard
and had lots of injuries
but regardless of that today my outer
body is going to talk to my inner body
and ask a question what that question
will be
usually varies i'm going to smile with
the backs of my eyes
as if i'm smiling
i might be in a bad mood i don't know
why but i may just be in a bad mood
i don't want to pass it on to people but
perhaps i can't help it
i rebel by being
difficult and yeah i have no idea why
today
i will be difficult
if i'm happy then i'm happy
those around me will be happy
this is unfair on them
so i will ask myself why am i unhappy
today
i feel a little vibration in my body as
if it's like a fear
i just ask her ask myself my inner body
a fearful question
perhaps i don't like the answer
even though i don't know the answer
the thought of getting an answer
why do i fear this
sensing
the question
and what i got from the question was
important
because it proves that i don't really
want to go
there or ask that question do i
there's something underneath all of
these questions
[Music]
perhaps it's time to be kind to myself
i shall from within look at the smile
within
i feel calmer now
[Music]
i don't need to answer the question now
because i'm very calm
and content
it's not overavoiding going back to ask
from the outer body to the inner body
the question
but if you're content why disturb that
[Music]
content
opening my eyes slowly
so what i got from that was
when i do a rise be pleasant to whoever
i meet
whether it's my partner my pet
the view that i look around me just
enjoy it
wherever you live however terrible it
may be
there's something to see
escape when you can
to your inner self
[Music]
i sense you didn't just do techniques
if you don't think that you have to do
more
you're disillusioning yourself
you have to do more if you want to get
closer to our senses i could have
and more importantly if you want to get
closer to yourself
your inner self your outer self
this body has to carry my mind
for the rest of my life as it always has
done
but the mind has driven this body beyond
many times what it should have been
driven
now my outer body is suffering because
of
it shoulder problems
arthritis in the knees in the hands
but i'm happy because i've found
a small portion of peace
thank you for listening
please join me if you wish on my patreon
site details below
remember you can always unsubscribe
you can go up and down in the tears
depending on
how you wish thank you for your time
so
[Music]
good
so
okay